Who is the god like
Yahweh the god of
wrath the god of Mercy The God
Who reaches down to unworthy people.
What a powerful testimony, right? Oh, thank
you for being vulnerable Kristen. I want
to pray for you now.
And invite you to pray with me for her as well
God. Thank you for her.
her heart for Kristen's willingness to
allow you to work in her life and
For your exposure of what was going on in her soul
that there was something that she was pursuing that
was not of you.
And so I pray you'd open our eyes to see it ourselves as
we need to.
Keep working in her her husband her family.
Thank you God for the work of this ministry.
May it continue to reach more even today.
In Jesus name amen.
Some grateful for the testimony also grateful for Aaron preaching
Psalm 51 last week while I was holding babies back there
in the nursery. It was it was fun, but I was
profoundly struck as Aaron said last week about
This idea how we often slip into saying, excuse me to
God rather than asking him to forgive us. That was just
so deeply searching of our hearts in that. So
if you haven't seen that go check it online on our
website from last week. But today we're picking back up
in our series through the Book of Micah in the
Old Testament just a few weeks left as we get into chapter 6
now.
There's only seven chapters. And so we're going to get to chapter 6
turn there with me if you're not already.
Micah 6
As we get into it today though, many of you know that one of the things
that I do with each one of our sons is take them
on what we have very creatively entitled 10
trip with that. So when they
hit their 10th birthday some around there I take each of them individually on
a big fun trip just there's no pressure on
it. It's just helping make memories and then help them
teach how to you know, like airports and
maps and all those things just to navigate the
city and stuff like that. Just really A Memory Maker
for example with my oldest and 2018. We
went to Atlanta and we did everything in Atlanta that
you can do we hit in four days Civil Rights
Museum Martin Luther King stuff, Coca Cola Museum aquarium,
the original Chick-fil-A, which kind
of felt like a pilgrimage of some sort. I don't know if you all need to do that, but that
was what we did there last year with
our middle son. He and I went all over Pennsylvania. We had
a great time in Philly cheesesteaks Pittsburgh, Hershey
Park Amish farm, the whole deal did all
of that.
And so our youngest son is going to turn 10 next
summer. And so he's been watching these for years just like
anticipating and waiting and planning and all of that.
But here's the thing about those trips.
Now it's not about what we do on those
trips.
Now the things we do are fun and unique and we try to
make it a big deal memory. Yes, but but as you're kind
of thinking through that with your family, you don't have to go big.
Just be intentional with what you're doing with your kids or with
your spouse.
Because what those boys want.
More than anything about a trip like that. What they
want is me.
They want time focused time with me as a
dad with his sons regardless of
what we're doing.
It's not about what they get to do.
It's who they get to do it with.
And listen, it's similar with God.
And it's not just I know you're thinking it's not just that we should
want God more than we want his gifts. Yes, that's true. But
But Micah 6 is going to show us that it's you.
Not something from you that God wants.
It's you.
not something that God wants
more than our religious rituals.
More than money or decorations in
our house.
More than our songs. God wants you your your
heart your life your desires Your
Love he wants you.
We'll see how Micah 6 shows that to us. Look at verses
1 through 8.
hear what the Lord says
talking to his people Judah here what the Lord says arise
plead your case before the mountains. Let the
hills hear your voice hear you mountains
the indictment of the Lord and you enduring foundations
of the Earth for the Lord has an indictment against his people
he will contend with Israel.
This is since God's saying oh my people what have I done to you how
have I we read you answer me?
For I brought you up from the land of Egypt and redeemed you
from the house of slavery.
And I sent before you Moses Aryan and Miriam.
Oh my people remember what balak king of Moab devised
and what Balaam the son of bjor answered him.
And what happened from shatim to gilgal that you may know the
righteous acts of the Lord.
And with what shall I come before the Lord and bow
myself before God on high?
Shall I come before him with burnt offerings with calves a year
old will the Lord be pleased with thousands of rams?
With 10,000 of rivers of oil.
Shall I give my first born for my transgression the
fruit of my body for the sin of my soul?
And he has told you o man. What is good? What does
the Lord require of you?
But to do justice and to love kindness and
to walk humbly with your God.
Now we need to remember where we've come so far in Micah.
Through the first five chapters. God has been threatening judgment on
his people because of their denial of his Covenant
principles his his Covenant relationship and
in both the leaders of the people and the people themselves
were turning their backs on God.
They were living unjust lives. They were oppressing the
poor. They were believing falsehoods about
God. They were worshiping other gods or worshiping
idols.
Now we know from Micah 5 that God was going to deliver his
people bring a deliverer through Bethlehem, and
and that was going to bring about in reinstation of
this kingdom of God. That would come on the Mountain Zion again someday.
But what we see is that God said to get there.
They're going to have to suffer.
They're going to have to be purified.
To be able to be on that mountain.
And so to expose the issues as he
goes back to his people that there were still relational Covenant
issues with them between them and the Lord.
To expose that the Lord brings a case against his people
here.
It might even say it on the heading that was added later
not original in the text of scripture, but they brought an
indictment. They brought a case against his people a legal
case because you look all over this passage. You see courtroom language,
right?
In verse 1 this arise suggests a
lawyer standing up to make his case.
You see this plead your case in verse 1. There's the
word indictment repeated in verse 2 even contend in
verse 2 is like this debate back and forth in
a courtroom setting.
Verse three God calls them out and says answer me.
So there's this this idea of a courtroom setting and
it's happening in this moment.
Which really is just been the whole book of Micah. Hasn't
it?
Where God has consistently through
Micah said to his people you're wrong here, you're sinning
here. You're wrong. Here's bringing a case before them even
to the point where God calls on the mountains and The Valleys
here.
as Witnesses
basically saying creation has watched you Judah.
You have no excuse. You can't stand this is what you've
been doing. They've seen it.
Okay, but what was the specific case? He's bringing here.
That's where we need to see a little deeper. What was
this case that God brought?
The first part of the indictment was where God says, they'd
forgotten his grace.
God says to them you have forgotten.
my grace
verse 3 said the people been complaining.
They were accusing God of being unfaithful.
And so God reminded them of a few things look again at Verses
4 and 5.
Says I brought you up from the land of Egypt redeemed you from
the house of slavery. I sit before you Moses. Aaron Miriam.
My people remember what balak king of Moab devised
what Balan the son of Biore answered him and what
happened from shatim to go gal that you may know the righteous acts of
the Lord.
He says remember what I've done now, there's a couple things
happening here first this this Redemption of
Israel out of slavery that's called The Exodus. It's
entire book of the Bible. It is the main thread
of the Old Testament.
It's why the old the Passover existed was
from that scene?
It's what they were charged to pass on to their children. Don't forget
this. Don't forget this. It's all over the Old Testament.
So we know that would be something God says. Hey remember I
did this.
But these other scenes in verse 5 either go look up.
Because like what did they have to do compared to the Exodus like
this seems a lot less important. I don't even know the names like
right. So so what is God talking about here?
He's actually talking about their entrance into the Promised Land.
The Exodus is there they're leaving at Egypt these
others are where they're now going into God's
Promise Land which happened in a very similar way
they left through the Red Sea is it split and then
they're going into the promised land the Jordan River split and
it's so it's it's like the entrance the exit and the entrance here.
And there's two scenes here first. He mentions this fun story from
Numbers 22 through 24 where there's this block
who is an enemy King from Moab.
He hired this Prophet famous Prophet named Balaam.
He says I want you to curse Israel.
Well God intervened.
And he turned that curse actually into a blessing
of his people.
And I say it's fun because it even involves a talking donkey like
from Shrek, right? That's it's a really good story. Go
read it later.
But then he says these two towns should team and gilgal. Why does
he say these towns? What do they have to do with anything?
Well shettim was where balak lived that
was that king of Moab. That's where he lived and it was the last stop on
the Eastern side of the Jordan River
before they would have crossed into the promised land
and then gilgal was the first stop on the
other side of the river once they're in the land.
And so don't think of them as like rest stops on the interstate
where they just happened to walk through those towns. There's a lot going on here
because she team was the place where actually a
lot of Israelites succumbed to moabite idolatry.
Like they're on the border of the promised land
and they still said no we want to follow these other gods.
And so when God says here, hey remember I took you
out of Egypt and I brought you in from shateim to
gilgal remember.
I'm declaring to you my faithfulness that
in spite of your idolatry.
I brought you into the promise.
Now we know not all of them made it.
But in spite of that he says both should
team and gilgal. He says I did it.
I opened the river to bring you in.
That's why God was reminding them of all of this because the
end of verse 5 remember it says that you may know the righteous
acts of the Lord.
He's talking about God saving work in their
life that he delivered his people out of Egypt. He provided
leaders for them through the Wilderness. He saved them
from these evil Kings.
And then he brought them mercifully into the
Promised Land.
And the whole point of that?
all that
was to change them.
Was to bring them into make them into
this chosen set apart nation that
he had originally intended them to be that Israel was
supposed to be distinct.
And he did all of this to show them
that.
But they'd forgotten.
They'd forgotten God they'd forgotten
his grace.
They'd forgotten what he had done for them
and instead of remembering and just being so thankful.
They started complaining.
And they started growing tired of God.
Could God bring the same case against us?
against you
we are so similar to them, right?
This this quote I read this week. Listen the mercies
of a lifetime.
Are often ignored by us under the
bitterness of a single trial?
We say that again the mercies of a lifetime are often ignored
by us under the bitterness of a single trial.
May we never forget what God has done Church.
He's been so good to us in countless ways.
And I know in the moment. Sometimes it's hard to remember some of those things. You might
be like, what am I looking for? I can't remember anything that God's been good
to me. Don't forget all that. He's done to save you.
I mean God himself.
Lived died and resurrected to deliver your
soul.
If you believe that if you are his then that is something you
can hold on to that's good news.
And you can remember that that's why we sing The Gospel. That's why
we preach the gospel. That's why we memorize God's word.
That's why we speak the gospel to one another in groups. That's
why we build relationships like that because the more we
remember that
the more we're changed.
We can't forget.
What God's Grace has done?
But you notice that wasn't the only indictment that he brought
against his people here.
It forgotten his grace. Yes, but apparently they'd also
misunderstood his requirements.
They misunderstood his requirements as his people. What
were they supposed to do?
I'm gonna go back and read verses 6 and 7 again but
notice as I read this he's shifted Micah shifted
to almost saying rhetorically something that
they would be saying as the people he's putting words in their mouth
so to speak.
Verse 6 with what shall I come before the Lord and bow myself
before God on high shall I come before him
with burnt offerings with calves or you're old will the
Lord be pleased with thousands of Rams with 10,000 of
rivers of oil?
Even more absurdly shall I give my firstborn my child
for my transgression the fruit of my body for the sin of
my soul meaning should I put my child on that altar?
God is that what you want?
So basically what Mike is simulating here is
they're trying to defend themselves here in this case.
They're basically saying God have you not seen all the
things that we've brought before you not see what we
give you over and over and over again God. Why do
you find fault in US?
Look at how much we're giving you.
But you can tell these questions have a negative assumption,
right?
The answer is probably negative to those that God will
not accept all these sacrifices and these
religious actions as the way to get closer to him.
Even if those sacrifices are like over the
top or as we've heard it in the last few years huge, right,
even if they're huge sacrifices that
you have over the top again, and again even in
that he's not primarily concerned with the size and
the cost of those gifts.
He would not accept their sacrifices. Why because
they're worshiping with the wrong attitudes.
Because it's not in here.
Because they're living for themselves out there.
They're doing everything they want to do they're walking their own Road and
yet in here then they're trying to buy God off.
Can we not get to the same place?
Can we not put on an outward display of
religious Behavior to cover up
what we're really about in the rest of our lives?
Listen, if you've been around the church at all for anything like the time, you know, that's my
story for 20 years.
I was the good church kid when everything about the rest of
my life looked completely opposite to that.
That's what they were doing even today.
I can fall into the Trap of thinking
that God will love me more if I just do this
or do that or do that come make it a
deal with God. If I do this, you're gonna do this for me and that's where
we slip into right? It's what they were facing.
That's why we must must remember the fundamental point
today.
That it's your whole life not something from
you that God wants.
He wants you your whole life everything about
you. Not just stuff. Not just something not just
your money. He wants you.
You can do all kinds of stuff. That seems Christian.
But if your heart is far from him, it's all
worthless.
He wants you.
Which all of that?
Sets up our study here of verse 8.
Because you heard them ask the question in verses 6 and 7.
How can we please God?
You saw that question. What's he going to accept?
Who can Ascend his Hill certainly? Something's got
to get us there, right? How can we get to him? Who who can
please God in any way?
But thankfully God gave them the answer.
Here in verse 8. He boils it down.
He distills out the three basic requirements of what
it means to be his people.
looking at verse 8
He has told you o man. What is good meaning? This isn't the
first time they've heard this stuff.
He's already told you. What is good. What does the Lord require of
you but to do justice and to love
kindness and to walk humbly with your God.
So if God says these are the three most important things to
them at this time in history, like we need to understand those things,
right?
Especially since as you're reading and you're translation, maybe it says different things. We
need to understand what God is actually saying here.
There's some clarity on these things. And so the
first one I would translate like this act justly.
What does god require?
That we would act justly the word. It's in mind
says do justice.
Act justly live justly because remember remember
the word for for justice in Micah. It
means this right social relationships
based on God's view of what's right. And
what's appropriate
so they're living it out. As God would say they
should live it out.
That in light of his Covenant people would mutually respect one
another and they would they would protect those who
are the most vulnerable.
We always talk about the Proverbs 31 Woman. This is
the proverbs 31 man verses 8 and 9
says open your mouth for the mute for the rights of
all who are destitute open your mouth judge righteously
defend the rights of the poor and needy.
That's Justice. According to God's word.
Because remember it in Micah both the
leaders and the people had been stealing land and
oppressing the poor.
And so he's turning around and reminding them of this just standard
that God says no we are to defend the rights of those people.
We are to protect them we are to act justly.
Because that's how God says we should act towards one another.
It works similarly for us today that since God is
just that's part of his nature. We ought
to reflect that image to the world around us.
So when we say act justly that doesn't mean you get to bring your own Justice with
you and firing away at everything or it
doesn't mean you get to judge others because you are doing Justice
or acting justly. It means that you should be
I should be the fairest and most Equitable
person on the face of the Earth.
That we respect the Dignity of every person who also Bears
the image of God.
Which is all of us.
That's what Justice means. It's right social relationships
based on what God says is right.
And that doesn't just mean on the outside.
That means even on the inside in our hearts that we
are longing for the justice that God brings.
That one day listen one day will come in full form when
the Messiah returns.
But we can live out those Kingdom principles even now.
We long for that.
We act justly towards seeing that Justice come.
So act justly second. He says we ought
to love faithfulness.
love faithfulness
Yours might say love Mercy or love kindness. Why'd I
say faithfulness? Well, this is because the word for that
Mercy kindness faithfulness is the
Hebrew word. I've said it before with the little get the
throat into it right I said,
That's the word that means so much more than we can Define.
It's the most commonly used word for the character of God.
That it means steadfast Covenant loyalty and love
and faithfulness. It just means all this stuff all put
together.
these faithful
and so we are called to love faithfulness.
to love that has said
so that means then if we're to love that means to be
an active participant in it reflecting.
That commitment.
Both to God and to others in light of his commitment to us.
If we have been called into his Covenant relationship vertically, we're
called to give that to others to be committed to
him. Yes, but then committed to others. It's
what first John 4:19 says.
we love
because he first loved us.
He faithful to us and so
we're faithful to others.
To love that faithfulness and
so think about that.
Yes, of course vertically with God, but think about it in light
of God's faithfulness to you.
Are you?
Dedicated to God's people as well.
If this is what God says to love this kind
of cassette faithfulness, then yes be committed
to him. But he also says that's the way it should play out in life.
So are you dedicated to God's people?
Do you love faithfulness?
By just being with others attending worship Gatherings
making sure you're part of a group with people.
Looking for ways to reimagine your generosity to
them looking for ways to serve other believers in
the church. How how are you committed to serving and
and being in this test said
relationship?
horizontally
or are you merely a consumer doing what
is convenient?
That's because this this faithfulness from
God to us is the example.
It's not just convenience.
It's above and beyond.
That's the way we are to be for one another.
Lovingly committed like he is towards
us.
There's one more category here in verse 8. Probably the
most important one. So it's the one we're going to spend the most time on.
It's this phrase walk humbly with your
God.
walk humbly with your God
There's no translation differences here. That's what it means walk humbly
with your God, but what we often do with this one.
Is we narrow that down to just simple humility?
And we say welcome to the God. So be humble put away Pride put
away air against and just be humble now hear
me. I'm agreeing with you. That's true.
But there's so much more to this phrase than just be humble.
When we dig down into the depths of this the
essence of this one is humility true humility
before God.
That we have humbly submitted
this walk which by the
way the word walk is used all over scripture to illustrate the
way you live your life.
That's what we talk about your walk with Christ.
It doesn't mean you're like literally walking next to him. It means you're living your
life with him in light of him. We'll get
to that here in a second, but that we have humbly submitted our
law.
To him as our King and we're willing to follow him wherever he leads.
Remember when the angel came to Mary? This is
Luke 1:38, the angel came to marry and said
you were going to Bear Jesus you're gonna have this baby miraculously named
Jesus Savior the world. What did
she say?
She said let it be to me according to your word.
She's like, I don't understand this.
This is gonna get hard. People are gonna
look at me funny all of these things, but she says Okay
God.
your word
Because just think about this phrase again walk humbly
with your God.
This is a relationship. So in that relationship.
Should you be the one leading that walk?
No.
Come on, Jesus. Let's go right like no, that's not
how this thing should work the image. Here's the image. I got in my head this week.
It's like
so imagine Jesus walking down a pathway
and then I'm his child and
I'm just crouching like right back here right
behind him just settled behind him, but just
clinging to his arm.
And this I couldn't get this picture out of my head of just like
walking with him and just well almost like when you're
got your grandkids coming over and they just wrap their arm around
your leg and just sit on your foot and you gotta kinda like drag them along
despite kids Despicable Me when the girl wraps on
the cruise leg that kind of thing, right? That's what I'm talking about. It's
that image of of just grabbing his arm
and just following
just walking humbly.
with your God
because in that what you've said is I've submitted to
jesus' Direction.
Like I want to follow him wherever he
goes. I don't care where you're going Jesus. I just want to be with you. I'm just
gonna follow you're going this way. I'm going this way and I'm gonna love what you
love. I'm gonna see what you see. I'm humbly walking with my
God.
But again, that's the point here.
The question was how do we please God?
It's clearly as we've seen not through rituals
and sacrifices.
In an effort to buy him off or to cover up
my sin and if I've sinned again, I better do more of
these things. I better do more quiet times better give more money. I better
go to church and all of that is not how we're
pleasing God what he wants
is you
He wants your heart. He wants your love. He
wants your life. He wants you.
Not something not stuff. He wants you.
remember last week in Psalm 51
It's what David wrote.
As he was confronted with his sin David wrote this Psalm 51
verses 16 and 17 to God.
You will not Delight in sacrifice, or I would give it.
You will not be pleased with a burnt offering here's what
you'll be pleased by he says the sacrifices of God
are a broken spirit.
A broken and contrite heart o God, you
will not despise.
You have to get there in order to say to
Jesus. I'm going with you.
Wherever you go. My heart is broken. My
spirit is broken blessed are the poor
in spirit Matthew 5:3 for they they saw sons
of God like I'm right here with you.
Because here's what happens the more you walk with
God like that the more you walk with Jesus like I
described you clinging to him the more you walk like
that the more you begin to reflect his
image and character to the world.
That's how this thing works.
Because think about it, you're going to go where he goes. You're gonna love
what he loves you're gonna see what he sees. You will begin
to love faithfulness more readily you'll begin
to act justly more regularly. These things will
come up because you're just following along with Jesus as the perfect
example of all of those things.
He's going to do it through you. You're gonna watch him.
You're gonna learn how he does it and you're going to do it alongside him.
The humble submission to letting the Lord direct Our
Lives is where everything else begins to flow
from.
you just follow him and he
Does all of it through you?
And so as good as that sounds though.
I mean we're sitting here thinking yes, of course right now. I'm even
sitting here. Yeah, great.
But here's where the rub comes on this.
You and I so often.
instead of
humbly submitting and Walking with God
you and I choose to stand in opposition to God.
And we stand in opposition to Jesus instead of pulling alongside
him and grabbing his arm. We stand in opposition to
him debating his direction for our lives pushing back
on his commands for our lives wanting our
own will instead of his will to
be done.
It's all over the Book of Micah. That's what Judah was
doing. Right they that we just like they we like
going our own way.
We enjoy our own path.
We don't want to submit.
But you and I know.
What happens with that we end up exhausted?
We end up hurt.
We end up burdened.
And we bring destruction on our own lives and on
lives of those around us that we love.
So we feel that.
Hear me today.
If that's what you're all right now.
If that's where you're at.
And you feel like you have stood in opposition you feel burned out
and you feel exhausted and you feel heard in
this pain if that's what you're feeling is separation, and you've been
opposed to even separated from if that's what you're feeling
hear me. Jesus is standing there with his
scarred hands wide open wanting you
to come to him and just let him wrap his
arms around you.
Because he knows you hurt. He knows what happens when you
walk away from him. He knows you're not okay.
And he wants to he wants you to release that
pain as he just hugs you and you cry
sobbing into his chest because you're
just releasing the pain that you felt he wants you
to give up control and let him just rap his arms around
you.
What a privilege that is, right.
Just think about that. Why do we run away
from that embrace?
What why do we push away from the
joy that we find in
his presence?
Why do we stand in opposition and say Jesus? No, not
your way my way instead of Jesus saying no,
just come here. Just come in here.
And release the weight.
Come to be all her weary and burdened. I'll give you rest.
Why do we push back and force our
way out of his Embrace and say no Jesus? I don't want your way.
And listen, I'm the first to say I know how hard it is
to die to your own will.
To die to your self, but do
not forget something in this humbling process. You are
humbling yourself before the god of your salvation.
The God Who already loves you
You don't have to try to prove yourself to him anymore.
You don't have to put on this facade before other people
that you have it all together. You don't have to do
that anymore. You can just remember that he loves you that he's
lived and died and resurrected for you
and he's wanting you just to run into his arms where
you're done. You're just finished with yourself and
you're willing to walk humbly with your God now.
Not just a God by the way. Did you hear that?
Not just a God. Not just the God Walk humbly
with your God.
That this God of the universe who
is Sovereign and in control also wants to
just hold you Safe in His Arms
wherever you go.
Listen, remember more more than religious Behavior.
More than being a good person.
More than you're giving more than you're singing more
than you're lifting hands and and looking super Christian. He
wants you he wants all of you.
Every corner of your heart he wants you to open it
up and just say I'm Yours.
Because he knows that when he has you when he has all of
you your whole heart when you let him
lead you then all that other stuff will start to
flow out of you naturally.
Everything that he wants of you everything he's requiring
of you. That's where it starts.
So don't see this as a burden Church.
Don't see any of this as a burden.
See this that the god of the universe once this
kind of daily living relationship
with you.
And so how do you cling to Jesus? You can't see him. How do you how do
you do this? How do you get around his arm and and walk with how do
you do that? You do that through his word you soak in
his word reading about him praying back to him having this communication
with him consistently constantly throughout
the day you're meditating on his gospel that
he saved you you're praying and inviting him saying Jesus.
I'm going to school. I'm going to to work. Can you
show me how I'm supposed to do this today?
That's how you cling to him.
You focus on him above everything else. That's what it means
to cling to Jesus.
But also listen, unbeliever. I want to talk to you for a second here.
I hope you see today.
That this is the God we worship.
He's not merely about getting you
to do certain things or to not do certain things.
He wants to be in relationship with you.
Just like you were designed to be originally and everything else is
going to be futile. Everything else is going to be fallen he wants this living
relationship with you.
And so whether you're a Believer or not today?
The invitation is to run into his
arms your daddy's arms and
just bury your face in his chest.
sometimes
Lead Me
His arms are open wide for you today.